welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of 2011's
X-Men first Class the fifth installment
of our X-Men Snick snicked rewatch as we
break down all 13 of the fox X-Men and
Deadpool films ahead of Deadpool 3 this
movie was a prequel SL reboot to the
X-Men films that came before and so it
recasts some high-profile roles for a
look at the start of Charles Xavier
school and its friendship and subsequent
rivalry with Eric linster Magneto let's
break down this film scen by scene for
all the Easter eggs the links to the MCU
and as always if you want to avoid any
potential dead three spoilers I will
leave all of that conversation for the
deaner room at the end of this video and
to celebrate this X-Men rewatch we are
doing a special X-Men themed merch
release which is really the best way to
support new rockstars grab one of these
designs by clicking the link in the
description the film opens in Poland in
1944 director Matthew vau recreated the
opening sequence of the 200000 X-Men
film shot for shot with different actors
this time the sequence continues after
young Eric lyncher is knocked out the
camera pans up to show Sebastian Shaw
played by Kevin Bacon watching ing out
his rain soaked window while sipping a
cup of tea like the K the Frog meme but
you know a Nazi we're also reminded of
the American officers toasting with
champagne during Wolverine's origin
story Matthew vau had been hired to
direct The Last Stand originally but he
backed out due to some time constraints
and he said later a Fallout with Fox
Executives over a bogus fig script
designed to trick halib Berry but he was
thrilled to be brought back for this
film he actually came on in this movie
having just finished directing kickass a
movie known for having both quick
Silvers in it Aaron Taylor Johnson and
Evan Peters hey remember in W Vision
when w said kickass and we all lost our
minds around the same time Eric lyncher
powers are manifesting in Poland a young
Charles Xavier sleeps in his lonely but
cozy Castle in Westchester New York next
to his bed are a baseball a book and
frame photos of Charles Darwin whose
namesake appears later in this film and
Rita Hayworth in a still from the film
You Were Never Lovelier and Albert
Einstein though this particular photo of
Einstein wasn't taken until 1947 3 years
after this particular scene is set we
all learned exactly what Einstein was
doing at this point in his life from the
movie Oppenheimer also in the Last Stand
Kitty Pride discussed Einstein with
professor Savior and he responded Yes
but Einstein was not a mutant as far as
we know the actor playing 12-year-old
Charles is Lawrence Belcher who was cast
after Charlie roow dropped out due to
conflicts with shooting the film
Neverland young Raven future Mystique
breaks into Charles's house looking for
food and takes on the form of his mother
he immediately knows is not really his
mom since she'd never be this warm to
him his quick distress is something in
line with their relationship in the
comics after her husband's death Sharon
Xavier remarried Dr kurtt Marco who had
a son from a previous marriage Kan Marco
Juggernaut who we saw in the Last Stand
Dr Marco was abusive and drove Shar to
alcoholism and depression so she became
neglectful of Charles so yeah she
probably wouldn't be in the kitchen
making him hot chocolate Charles is
thrilled to meet another mutant and
Raven is thrilled that he's not
immediately afraid of her in her natural
blue skinned form he essentially adopts
her as a sister kind of like Wendy did
with the lost boys and Peter Pan and
without proper legal or parental
permission in the comics mystique and
Charles's relationship varies sometimes
their childhood friends and sometimes
their enemies they were technically
married at one point but that's been
pretty much ignored meanwhile Sebastian
Shaw plays Lai on Rose by Edis PF on the
photograph like the photo of Einstein
this would be anachronistic that song
was actually recorded in 1946 2 years
after this scene takes place the song
though is about seeing the world through
rose-colored glasses finding the
positives or beauty in everyday life
other Ed the PF songs have been featured
in Loki Agents of Shield Falcon Winter
Soldier this song featured in Inception
Shaw will later play the same song later
on in the hellfire club in 1962 ironic
though that he's playing it there which
would be the most awful setting possible
seban Shaw offers Eric some chocolate
this is something Nazi scientist yoseph
mangala would actually do to children
before conducting horrible Eugenics
experiments on them and he says
the
fite there is an actual X-Men comic
series called Uncanny X-Men the new age
written by Chris Claremont in his return
to the X-Men world he was responsible
for creating a lot of Magneto's
backstories so this line about the new
age might be the film's way of paying
homage to him unlike the first X-Men
when Charles opened the film talking
about evolution of mutation as a natural
occurrence Shaw is trying to force
mutation through any means necessary
while the Nazis want to use Eugenics to
breed traits like blonde hair and blue
eyes he wants to use it to create more
mutants there's a really cool reveal
when the camera flips to show that this
whole conversation has been taking place
next to a lab with various weapons and
medical torture devices it makes the
audience realize that sha has just been
doing this whole act offering chocolate
distancing himself from the Nazis with
this looming threat negating everything
Shaw tries to get Eric to move the coin
using only his mind and in a true check
off's gun moment this is the very coin
that Eric will use to kill Shaw later
after he shoots Eric's mother and
activates his powers Shaw actually hands
him the coin to keep the instrument of
his own destruction the image of the
coin in Eric's Palm flips up to reveal
the title of the film and then we fast
forward 18 years to Geneva Switzerland
in 1962 Eric now uses his powers to move
the coin through his fingers which is
reminiscent of him keeping the Newton's
Cradle ball swinging using only his mind
in the first film it's the sort sort of
mental busy work that successfully shows
Mastery over his powers he has a board
with all the Nazi players he wants
revenge on and some string connecting
them all there's a handdrawn picture of
Shaw which Eric presumably Drew himself
and black and white photos of some other
people the fact that there's no photo of
Shaw makes me think that he keeps a low
profile we find out later that his
powers keep him young so it would make
sense that he doesn't want photographic
evidence of his seeming immortality Eric
drives the coin into the photograph for
shadowin Shaw's death at the end of the
film at a bar in Oxford University a now
24 y- old Charles Xavier played by James
back boy uses his knowledge of mutations
to hit on Amy a co-ed with heterochromia
a mutation producing two different
colored eyes Jason Striker William
Striker's son had one green eye and one
blue eye just like this woman does I
wonder if she's somehow related to him
she's played by Annabelle Wallace who
played Grace on pey blinders and was
also the lead in the crazy horror film
malignant James makoy was the first
actor cast for this film and after he
got the role he shaved his head before
learning that it was a period piece that
they wanted him to have 60 style hair so
they had to give him hair extensions for
much of the film before it grew back he
would shave it again correctly this time
for X-Men apocalypse after Charles
orders Amy a drink he touches his Temple
indication that he's using his powers to
see what she likes Raven bristles at
this flirtation and at Amy who obviously
isn't real mutant saying that they
should reclaim the word and coining the
phrase mutant and proud mutant and proud
are settling with pretty mutations or
invisible ones like yours but if you're
freak better hide this actually comes up
a few times for mystique but it connects
to X2 which it tells Nightcrawler that
they shouldn't have to hide who they are
then V not stay in Disguise all the time
you know look like everyone else cuz we
shouldn't have to X-Men has always had
parallels to both the civil rights
movement and with the film starting in
2000 LGBT rights and the phrase mutant
and proud is similar to Sentiments like
gay pride or other LGBT slogans like
we're here we're queer get used to it
Raven asks Charles if he' date her as
her true self and it's definitely hurt
that he avoids answering this sets up
how much it means to her later on that
Eric wants to be with her in her true
form and helps explain her loyalty to
him over the years although she does
sell him out in the Last Stand after she
gets shot with a cure and he abandons
her the Swiss bank manager that Eric
goes to get information from is played
by James Falkner Randall tle from Game
of Thrones his photo is actually one of
the ones on Eric's spard in his hotel
room Eric is able to prevent him from
pressing the bank alarm because he's
wearing a watch with metal in it big
mistake melting down gold fillings was
horribly actually something the Nazis
did Eric turns it on the bank manager
here and we get a shot the metal filling
flying out of his mouth from inside his
mouth Sebastian Shaw's club in Las Vegas
is called Atomic in the comics Children
of the atom was a phrase used to refer
to mutants there was even a video game
with this title released in the '90s
Moira mctaggert recast here as Rose
Burns Stakes it out Matthew Von wanted
this film to be sort of a soft reboot of
the franchise if necessary so he told
the actors not to study or base their
performances on the actors who came
before them he nicked Mo as Scottish
accent that she had in the animated
series and in The Last Stand when she
was played by Olivia Williams this is
also why James McAvoy who actually is
Scottish has a slightly different accent
that Patrick Stewart used morira isn't a
scientist here she's a CIA agent keeping
tabs on some major players is that
Colonel Henry yes it is that's three mob
bosses the Italian Ambassador and the
CEO of Lockheed they can all be
Communists it's hellfire club it's got
to be something else this is the first
mission of the hellfire club in the
X-Men film franchise in the comics the
hellfire club was a secret society
introduced during the dark Phoenix Saga
and Uncanny X-Men number 129 over the
years they worked both with and against
the X-Men depending on whether their
interests aligned Colonel Hendry is
played by Glen morer who also played
General Jacobs and Agents of Shield and
has a recurring role in the Transformers
movies General morer he plays a lot of
military guys Emma Frost greets him at
the door she's played by January Jones
who when this film came out was better
known as Betty Draper from the madman
series and while perfectly cast in my
opinion in that show she really doesn't
bring much to this role or really to
most other projects as Sebastian Shaw
big dogs Colonel hindry to pressure him
into putting jipper missiles in Turkey
he once again plays Lavon Rose so this
is clearly his preferred music to hear
before doing terrible stuff Henry's been
drinking champagne like the military men
during the Weapons X procedure and
Wolverine's X-Men flashbacks there's
also a bowl of M&M's on the table and
there are blue ones in there even though
blue M&Ms weren't introduced until 1995
hey maybe we're just in an alternate
timeline where you know everything just
kind of got jostled around a couple
years in the room with them is also
yanos casted AKA Riptide we saw this
character briefly at the end of X-Men
Origins in the comics he can spin his
body super fast and he has the ability
to generate bone-like growths that he
could release when he was doing that
hurricane thing for the film The growths
were taken out and now he can just spin
hurricanes from his hands he also wore a
lot of purple in the comics and the
suits he wears in this film often has a
purple tinge to them Moira finds Russian
documents that translate to something
like report contains strategic missile
forces defense capability preventative
deployment Emma Frost's Diamond skin
looks different from the effect used for
Emma Silver Fox with the diamond skin
from the end of X-Men Origins visual
effects designer John dictra said that
this was because in origin she was only
seen briefly and didn't move much for
this film they wanted to make sure that
she had a full range of motion and
facial expressions if you're looking for
an easy way to pamper yourself revamping
your daily hygiene routine is a great
place to start in geology is here to
help geology is a 29 time award-winning
skin hair and body care company
recognized in men's health OA daily hype
Beast birdie Esquire and GQ geology's
products use just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have been
trusted by dermatologists for decades
geology can help you fight acne reduce
oiless prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging you don't
know where to start geology can create a
simple and effective skincare or hair
care routine for you all you got to do
is take a quick 30second quiz right now
if you use code new rockstars 100
geology will give you 100% off their
award-winning skincare trial set you'll
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30% off one skin hair or body product
when you add it to your trial so 100%
off plus an additional 30% off hope you
save some champagne because this is a
deal we're celebrating click the link in
the description or go to G
l. Rockstar 100 to get started Frost
whistles for AEL and he teleports in
he's played by Jason Fleming who has
been in a ton of stuff including the
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen as Dr
jeo and Mr Hyde the character Charles
brings up later in this film as well as
the guy Richie Banger Lock Stock in two
Smoky barrels which also starred Last
Stand Juggernaut actor Vinnie Jones and
was produced by Matthew Von Von
considers fliming something of a good
luck charm because the movies he puts
him in have historically done better
than the movies that he's not in in the
comics a zazil and Mystique are the
parents of Nightcrawler clearly he got
the teleporting from his dad and the
blue skin from his mom Simon kinberg who
wrote this film said that he and Brian
Singer wanted to make a zazil mystique's
father in these films but it never made
it into the finished product in the War
Room James Remar plays the unnamed US
general he was also an Oppenheimer and
he played Dexter's dad Harry on Dexter
the war room looks very similar to the
one in Doctor Strange Love that was also
a movie about preventing nuclear war
with the Russians the guy on the phone
even kind of looks like the president in
Doctor Strange Love who of course was
played by Peter sers Charles gets the
title that everyone knows him by in the
first film professor of genetics Charles
Francis Exavier in Argentina Eric
catches up with two more men on his Nazi
murder board they're played by ludgar
pistor and Wilfred haker who also played
Nazis and Eng glorious bastards which
also starred Michael fast bender and had
a similarly awesome scene set in a bar
now a deleted scene would have shown
Eric arriving at the Argentina airport
and flashing back to a memory of him
with his
[Music]
mother he actually bring this memory up
later in this film as one he had
forgotten after Charles unlocks it so it
makes sense why they would delete him
remembering it here this insanely tense
scene in the bar where we're just
waiting for something to happen is
absolutely awesome but unlike the scene
in a glorious bastards where Michael
Fender is worried about Nazis finding
him out theyve turned the tables now and
the Nazis are now the ones who are sort
of undercover but not really we just
haven't really seen Eric kick ass in
this way yet since in the earlier films
he was mostly using his powers or
relying on the Brotherhood to do the
physical fighting the guy who claims to
be the pig farmer says in German we were
under orders a common referring to
people who have done horrific deeds and
it's interesting that these men are
playing checkers whereas Eric lyncher is
almost always shown playing chess like
they literally cannot compete with him
on his level and like he did with the
cops and X-Men 2000 when he turned their
guns on them Eric forces this
bartender's gun to the man claiming to
be a tailor and mentally pulls the
trigger we get a point of view shot down
the barrel of the gun just like when
Eric pulled out the Banker's fillings I
just love that in the midst of all this
Eric takes the time to finish his beard
like you can see Eric playing out the
fantasy that he had played through in
his mind for years and just savoring
every moment of this and once again we
get a contrast with Eric's life and
Charles's life as Eric is hunting down
Nazis drinking a beer after a kill
Charles is drinking and partying in a
bar definitely shows how these men were
just on separate paths long before they
met Charles again is hitting on someone
by telling her she has quote a very
groovy mutation James maoy said that he
was playing this Charles almost like a
different character than Patrick Stewart
and here he's a little bit of a dog like
he used that line on Moira even while
the woman he used it on earlier was
sitting a couple feet away clearly
waiting for him Moira ain't buying this
crap though she's all business in Miami
Hendry turns down Shaw's offer of
champagne this time much like Striker
refused to drink an X2 these are both
men who've seen some crap they know
better than a drink around mutants a
deleted scene would have shown hindry
arriving to find Shaw casually hanging
out with a bunch of Cuban military
leaders cavos
made Colonel
Henry oh tro trano everything's fine we
can all be friends here good to see you
again Colonel Shaw's boat which we saw a
photo of at the bar earlier is the
Casper Tina Matthew Von also named the
flying boat in the film Stardust
starring Charlie Cox the Casper the
names are a mashup of Von's children's
names Casper and Clementine Charles
meets with some very important people at
CIA headquarters in Langley Virginia but
this Langley facility wasn't actually
built until 1968 but you know it
probably felt more cinematic to show
than the random series of buildings
where CIA headquarters were before then
also you know the timeline just got like
shaken it up it think got all kind of an
acronis whatever mat Von clearly just
doesn't care as Charles gives his
presentation on human genetic mutation
the graphic image on the left hand side
of the slide actually looks like the
X-Men logo this is an x-ray
crystallography image of the DNA
molecule Charles shows off his powers I
didn't really expect you to believe me
given that all you could think about
during my presentation was what sort of
pie they were serving in the
commissary it's Apple pean the other man
in the room is William Striker senior
Papa of future Wolverine creating
billain from X2 and Xmen Origins to
convince him that he's telling the truth
Raven turns into Striker senior just as
she would years later into his son when
he was played by Brian Cox and the way
that she turns into like half the people
in the US government the one other guy
in the room who's excited to meet the
mutants is played by Oliver Platt
credited only as man in black suit
Oliver plat I love this guy he's been in
everything FX Fargo series The Bear he
also played the general Council on The
West Wing Charles mentally communicates
with Mor after freezing everyone else
around her a trick that he pulled an x2
in the museum and with the president in
theal office at the end of that film
back at Shaw's boat Eric half emerges
from the water and this entire sequence
is very reminiscent of something you
might see in a James Bond film composer
Henry Jackman actually based his score
on John Barry's work in the those 007
films in the 60s another connection
comes up in the end
[Music]
credits the parallels between Shaw and
who Eric will become are evident in this
scene both have strong female bodyguards
standing at their side protecting them
Sean says we don't harm our own kind
which Eric has also said and obviously
both of them did and do harm other
mutants there are a bunch of other
similarities throughout the film that
I'll go into more Charles saves Eric
from drowning and reveals to Eric that
there are other mutant and the relief on
Eric's Face Bass Bender is just such an
amazing actor and these two guys are
really like a perfect pairing I mean
it's hard to match the skill and the
chemistry of Ian melen and Patrick
Stewart but I really think they're doing
it here I thought I was alone
Eric you're not the man in the black
suit brings the gang to a covert CIA
research base he's kind of like a fox
Moulder type if you ask me investigating
the Paranormal to getting made fun of
for it now he's got a team of mutants so
screw the haters is it Weir to be the
cia's new Mutant division
yes something like that New Mutants is
the name of a mutant team also created
by Chris Claremont as well as one of the
movies we'll get to later in the series
from 2020 it featured an all new all
different cast of X-Men including canol
Mirage Sunspot and wolf span similarly
this film features an allnew cast of
X-Men many of whom hadn't appeared on
screen before producer Lauren Schuler
Doner said that they originally started
to talk about doing a young mutants
movie while they were filming X2 with
the idea of it being that the characters
we'd already seen like Cyclops Jean Gray
storm in their early days at Charles's
school when they were still teenagers
after after delving into that idea she
decided it wasn't really working and
instead they needed to explore New
Mutants with new powers the audience
hadn't seen yet she agreed that the ones
in first class don't really go together
at first glance but the way they and
their powers interact just make it work
we meet young Hank McCoy played by
Nicholas Holt and Charles immediately
outs him to his boss how wonderful
another mutant already
here heck you didn't ask so I didn't
tell this is kind of a reference to the
don't ask don't tell military policy
that Bill Clinton adopted during his
presidency which is was considered
somewhat Progressive at the time but in
hindsight not really Hank shows everyone
what he can do Raven has a Mary Jane
Watson moment you're amazing you are
amazing Hank later flirts back in the
most nerdy scientist way possible taking
a blood sample while enjoying a romantic
meal of Twinkies and Coke but he's flirt
blocked by Eric did I hurt
you
kinky by the way if I look like you I
wouldn't change a thing and Raven's
interest starts to shift Magneto was
always very supportive of his followers
celebrating their mutinus and of course
in the original movies Mystique was very
comfortable in her normal appearance so
we're starting to see the seeds of that
getting planted here the helmet Shaw
Wars was designed by the Russians and
keeps pesky telepaths from reading his
thoughts and influencing him it's black
and gray here before Eric will give it
his paint job Eric steals some CIA info
on Sha and tries to leave like a thief
in the night but Charles stops him I
felt your Agony I can help you I don't
need your help don't kid yourself you
needed my help last night it's not just
me you're walking away from here you
have the chance to be part of something
much bigger than yourself Charles makes
a similar offer to Wolverine in the
first film if you remember Logan it's
been almost 15 years hasn't it living
from day to day moving from place to
place with no memory of who or what you
are shut
up give me a
chance I may be able to help you find
some answers around here there was a
deleted scene that would have shown
Charles unsuccessfully hitting on Moira
again this is my job Charles I
completely respect your decision read my
mind
now right yeah probably best say left
that one out in the original X-Men 2000
film Charles said Eric helped him build
cerebro but here it seems like Hank did
a lot of the word they call it
cerebro is in the Spanish for brain yes
the spherical room calls back the design
from the original movies it also kind of
looks like the spaceship earth dome in
Epcot Hank asks Charles if he won't let
him shave his head one of several
references throughout the film to the
fact that he'll later be totally bald
there are a few familiar mutants when
Charles uses cerebro the first time
including storm with her long white hair
and cyclops wearing sunglasses and
playing with a baseball the girl with a
ponytail and same shot of Cyclops is
maybe supposed to be Jean Gray but it's
not clear there's also this little kid
sitting in a chair reading a comic book
and we looked and we looked and we
looked and we tried to figure out what
exact issue of comics this was all I can
really tell is that the guy in the red
suit with the mutton chops kind of looks
like the early versions of Sebastian
Shaw so the first mutant that Eric and
Charles recruit is Angel Salvador played
by Zoe Kravitz she also played Leta L
strange in the Fantastic Beast films and
plays Selena Kyle and Matt Rees the
Batman in the comics she has the power
similar to a housefly including the
ability to shoot digestive acid at
people out of her mouth which we
actually see her demonstrate later a
deleted scene here would have shown
Charles using his powers to make Eric
appear like he's dressed as a
woman it's good isn't
it what in Days of Future Past we see a
screenshot of Angel's autopsy which puts
her death at around one week after the
events of this film oh next the GU
recruit Darwin played by Eddie gei Dev
from For All Mankind he has the ability
of reactive adaptation like he should be
able to adapt his body to Fit changing
scenarios and environments but we'll see
later this movie doesn't FL then they
meet Lucas Till playing Alex Summers AKA
havoc in the comics Havoc is Cyclops
brother he has the ability to transform
plasma energy into energy blasts till
played mcgyver in the recent reboot of
that show then they approached sea
Cassidy AKA Banshee played by Caleb
Landry Jones in an interview Jones said
that given his red hair in his freckles
he always knew he'd never get to play
Batman or Superman so when he heard what
they wanted for first class he was so
excited to finally get to be able to
play a superhero the visual effect of
Banshee scream was done through a
digital ring likee structure based on
renderings of sound waves then we get
what is many people's favorite part of
this movie this awesome Cameo from Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine excuse me I'm Eric
lentra tell Xavier don't [__] yourself
Jackman said that when he was approached
to appear he knew that this movie was
PG13 was excited that he was going to
get to say the one and only [__] in this
film The scripted line was [__] off but
he did one take where he improvised a
slight variation and that's the one that
made it in this Cameo makes him the
actor who played the same comic book
character and the most X-Men films and
since this is in the 60s this would be
before James howlet ever came across
team X or William Striker notice how
over his shoulder there's a neon sign
for Marv's beer which is a reference to
Matthew Von's production company Marv
films Charles and Eric play chess in
front of the Lincoln Memorial they play
chess many times throughout these films
also the World War II Memorial is
visible in front of the Washington
Memorial even though the World War II
Memorial wasn't built and open in the
public until 2004 at the research base
the mutant youths give themselves codeen
names they are comic monikers it's a
cool scene that shows the characters
goofing off and having some fun and
revealing the identities that they've
had to keep secret for so long but also
just a nice way of showing us what
everyone is capable of gives us some
context for the action that follows Alex
demonstrates his powers with the others
watching doing this sort of peeking
around the corner stacked heads thing
that is very John
hugheses get
back Lauren Scher Doner has said that
when the concept for the film was still
teen mutants in school one of the
reasons it wasn't working was because it
just felt too much like a John Hughes
movie but we would see in the MCU John
Watts totally used John Hugh's
Inspirations to make the Spider-Man
trilogy as good as it was Alex has
trouble aiming his power this is part of
his Arc in the film and is also shown in
the comics you can actually see some
Scorch marks on the side of the building
from where he missed his Target with one
of the blasts they immediately get
busted for partying and general teen
shenanigans on their way to the Russian
military Retreat Charles uses his powers
to make it seem like there's no one in
the back of the truck this is from an
extended scene that was actually cut
down the deleted part would have shown
the dog knowing they were
there can't you control it doesn't work
on animals too stupid I
think another deleted scene would have
shown more of Eric using his powers
against his soldiers than the military
Retreat Charles gets uncomfortable with
Eric's brutality as he uses metal to
choke Emma until she shifts out of her
diamond inform form Charles uses his
powers to see what Shaw is planning an
extended version of the scene would have
also shown Shaw sitting in the White
House Shaw's plan is pretty Bonkers
folks he's assuming that mutants are
children of the atom created by
radiation and therefore that they are
impervious to nuclear radiation this
seems like a wild thing to just assume
is true it's also kind of reminiscent of
Magneto's plan in the first movie when
he was going to use a device to either
mutate or kill all humans yet another
similarity between the two men in the
vision there is a logo of a blue flag
which is presumably the Hellfire club's
logo that would become the new one for
this new world it's similar to the one
from the comics just with the two
vertical lines that make up the H
removed it seemed like the filmmakers
wanted to link this one more closely to
the Nazi flag so it just kind of
combined the designs these two douchy
CIA guys mock the mutant group and Hank
shows them his trademark restraint by
just closing the curtains on them Shaw
attacks with a zazil teleporting people
high into the air and letting them drop
until it's basically raining suited
bodies it's just brutal it definitely
reminds me of Nightcrawler taking out
the Secret Service agents in X2 but at
least those guys survive Shaw gives them
the hard cell there's a Revolution
coming
each of us will face a
choice be
enslaved or rise up to rule Shaw
definitely intentionally looks at Darwin
when he says be
enslaved but again lots of parallels to
Magneto here politically they have a lot
of the same goals and are both very
skeptical when it comes to humans and
mutants peacefully coexisting the only
big difference is that sha lives as a
human not revealing his powers unless
absolutely necessary and he has never
really faced oppression whereas Eric was
oppressed for being Jewish and knows
what it's like like to be on that side
so he comes from a more experienced and
compassionate perspective that's why
Shaw wants to live like kings and queens
But Eric just wants mutants to be free
he pulls out the old if you're not with
us you're against us attitude that's a
favorite among dictators and just
generally terrible people he also says
you can stay and fight for the people
who hate and fear you or you can join me
this mirror is something Wolverine told
storm in the first movie the whole world
out there is full of people that hate
and fear you and you're wasting your
time trying to protect them I got better
things to do angel joins sha and Darwin
steps up and is done dirtier than any
other character in all of these movies
adapt to
[Music]
this adapt to this that's so mean to the
character and talking about the
filmmaker was mean to the character in
the comics Darwin survived some crazy
stuff and it just sucks that we didn't
get to see more of this character it's
also not a great look Matthew blond just
as for Darwin at the CIA Emma Frost is
in custody and there's a cool series of
shots where we hear the men talking
about her as the camera stays on her and
spins around then it's revealed that
they are not in the same room she is
using her powers to listen in on
everything that's been said at Charles's
Mansion he starts training the titular
first class and the comics the original
students that we met were Beast Gan gray
Cyclops Iceman and Angel there's some
real archival footage of John F Kennedy
and Nikita kushev in the days leading up
to the Cuban Missile Crisis which lasted
for 13 days during October 1962 this is
intercut with training scenes at the
mansion and the team is being outfitted
with sweet new gear Eric tries to get
Charles to shoot him in the head saying
that he can deflect it we saw him
control a bullet this way in the first
film pressing it midf fire against a
man's head a lot of these scenes had
extended sequences that were cut down in
the edit including ones of havoc and
Banshee training Alex for God's sake
don't just stand there pick up a fire
extinguisher and help me why you yelling
at me I warned you I'm sorry Alex but in
the field you could have killed one of
your teammates he asked me to cover him
Alex that's not what I meant I'm sorry I
didn't want to get involved it's not my
fault promise me one thing when I die
jumping out this window you got to bury
me in this pulling yourself together
there only one
[Laughter]
story Charles quotes Dr Jackal and Mr Hy
to Hank and summarizes Hank's struggle
as one to conform versus one of
accepting his true nature and the
literary references particularly apt
given his eventual transformation which
which comes from his desire to be normal
Hank laps Charles during their run a
move that Steve Rogers does to Sam and
Captain America Winter Soldier although
Hank catches up to Charles on his right
while Charles is helping the rest of the
team Eric helps Mystique if you're using
half your concentration to look normal
then you're only half paying attention
to whatever else you're
doing Hank explains that Raven cell's
age at half the rate of everyone else it
seems like it's this movie's way of
rectifying why she was still so young
looking in the other films whereas
Charles and Eric were like old men and
Ed version of the scene would have shown
Hank trying to recapture their earlier
interrupted romantic moment and
failing beautiful on the inside
huh and the
outside well this isn't really me though
is it
Hank I mean you might as well be
complimenting my shoes the training
sequence culminates with Charles asking
Eric to move the Satellite Dish calling
back the beginning of the film when Shaw
asks Eric to move the coin Charles of
course uses very different tactics ICS
and Shaw does and it contrasts the two
men nicely Charles unlocks an old memory
of Eric and his mother celebrating
Hanukkah when Charles says that there's
good in Eric really what he's talking
about is his capacity to love his powers
first activated when his loved ones were
threatened behind all that anger he felt
it was love that started it all and this
is what Charles is able to help Eric
connect to Shaw on the other hand said
it was anger that activated his powers
because he fundamentally misunderstands
love Hank presents Raven with a gift a
serum created using her DNA that will
make them look quote normal but she's
starting to accept who she is and urges
him not to take it Hank pulls an
absolute dick move telling her that her
natural blue form will never be deemed
beautiful and damn dude that's cold he
basically shoves her into Eric's arms
Eric and Charles play chess again Eric
criticizes Charles for thinking all
humans are like Moira and Charles gives
it right back saying Eric thinks all
humans are like Shaw this shows the
inherent flaws in both men's approaches
to the mutant human conflict of the
years then we get this line killing sure
will not bring you
peace peace was never an option and an
instant classic that has turned into
many many memes involving Angry Ducks
and just like Jackal Hank injects
himself and it goes horribly wrong
turning him into the Beast everyone is
familiar with when Raven attempts to
seduce Eric she transforms into Rebecca
Roma who of course played Mystique in
the original films But Eric says he
prefers the real raven and you know
she's been waiting her whole life for a
man to say this to her he's also the one
who encourages her to essentially go
nude likening her to a tiger and saying
no one would ever cover up a tiger
Charles as kind of horrified though as
anyone would be who found their adoptive
sister naked he asks if he has to read
her mind to figure out what's wrong and
she says he promised her he'd never do
that all of this helps explain why Raven
ultimately chooses to go with Eric in
the end a deleted scene after this one
would have shown Charles and Moira
sharing champagne in a kiss it is very
beautiful you
know what the mutated mcr1 G or hair
it's very beautiful it's a it's a
beautiful mutation mutation took us from
single celled organisms to the most
dominant form of life on the plan Hank
creates uniforms for everyone and
they're blue and yellow like the
original suits worn in the comics from
1963 until Jack Kirby's departure
BEAST's appearance in this movie is done
with makeup over CGI unlike the Last
Stand which was done with just makeup
and Prosthetics the situation in Cuba
heats up but Charles intervenes just in
time influencing this guy to abort the
launch this is actually similar to two
different real world events the first
took place in Cuba during the 1960s when
the United States Army detected a
Russian submarine off the coast of Cuba
and started firing upon it the Russians
out of contact with Moscow thought a war
might have broken out and wanted to Nuke
the American ships however one of three
men whose responsibility it was to
launch the nukes basil aripov refused to
give permission to launch Upon returning
to Russia they were reprimanded by
Russian officials until they should have
gone down with their ship rather than
risk Discovery by the enemy the second
event happened in the 1980s when sinos
laav Petro the man monitoring the
Russian nuclear detection system saw
readings that indicated the United
States had launched nuclear missiles at
Russia however Petro determined that the
readings were in equipment malfunction
and did not alert his superiors after
the fact both of the these men have been
labeled the man who saved the world but
neither of them were ever rewarded or
thanked by their government as the
Blackbird crashes Eric uses his powers
to hold Charles against the ceiling to
keep him from being thrown around the
plane this is a fake out moment which
leaves the audience wondering if this is
how Charles will lose the ability to
walk the effect of sha absorbing the
energy is really cool it looks like his
body is dividing to contain all of that
power the two sides face off an angel is
firmly on team bad guy now showing No
Reservations about fighting her old
friends Eric Gets a showdown he's wanted
since he watched sha kill his mother Sha
bust out every mental manipulation
tactic from the villain handbook I'm
sorry for what happened in the camps I
truly am but everything I did I did for
you to unlock your power to make you
embrace it Eric tearfully agrees with
sha that he made him stronger sha is the
Creator and Eric is Frankenstein's
monster Eric gets his helmet off and Don
it himself to block out Charles like
blocking out his conscience and then we
get the sickest moment of this movie if
you're in there I'd like you to know
that I agree with with every word you
said we are the
future
unfortunately you killed my mother later
on the MCU will Echo this moment when
Iron Man tells Captain America that he
doesn't care who the Winter Soldier is
just that he wants revenge because quote
he killed my mom and then Eric counts to
three just like Shaw did before he shot
his mother and the way makoy just
screams in pain during this it's like we
can feel the coin going through our head
but previously when he was training Eric
Charles told him that he could feel what
Eric felt when he was inside his mind I
think that's why he's really screaming
here because he can basically feel what
Shaw is feeling as a coin is driven
through his head this has communicated
really well with match cutting back and
forth between Charles and Shaw like the
framing is just perfect as the camera
Glides to the right also I think that
Eric does this really slowly so that
Shaw can't absorb the energy out of the
coin pushing against him or maybe he's
just doing it to torture him more
Striker senior wants to take out all the
mutants at once and he's even willing to
sacrifice Mora to do it yeah like father
like son they're whole family a dead and
just like Eric will do with the guns
outside that train station he slowly
turns the missiles in the WarHeads back
on the ships Eric tries to get him to
stop by saying the men on the ships are
just following orders and dude you know
he could have picked a different way to
convince him because that's exactly what
those Nazis in the bar said you know
it's not great as they fight Eric uses
his powers to fling the others back so
they can't intervene and notice that he
doesn't do this to Raven he already
knows that she's on his side Moira
shoots at him he deflects one of the
bullets which hits Charles's spine Eric
digs it out but it's too late this is
how he loses the ability to walk Eric
says I want you by my side we're
brothers you and I all of us together
protecting each other he always saw
mutant kind as his family which is why
he eventually goes on to call his group
the Brotherhood of mutants Eric tries to
recruit the others Raven Angel Riptide
and azil all go with him Beast Banshee
and Havoc stay with Charles producers
said they wanted the audience to see
Eric throughout the film is not
necessarily being wrong in what he was
trying to do so that when some ments
ultimately join him you can see why
Charles gets his signature x- wield
wheelchair despite the fact that he
trusts MOA he still makes her forget
everything about where he is and who
he's with so the CIA can't force it out
of her Eric breaks Emma out and he's now
in his red outfit fully embracing his
Magneto moniker the animation over the
end credits is based on those in the
opening credits of Dr No continuing with
the James Bond connection established
with the score it's also worth noting
that Stan Lee did not have a cameo in
this film and it's only the second time
in a Marvel film since X2 that he
doesn't show up there's also no mid or
post credit scene in this movie okay so
first class holds up pretty great movie
Matthew Von seemed more about the style
and the tone of going back to the swing
in60s but didn't really care about
nailing down the details still a lot of
fun up next in the series we'll be
breaking down James mangold's The
Wolverine from 2013 but first let's go
into the danger room where we're going
to discuss some possible Deadpool 3
spoilers so Matthew vaugh in recent days
said that he actually saw Snippets of
Deadpool 3 and he said that it would
give a jolt to Marvel Studios and
basically said it's going to save the
whole franchise but I am asking why
would V get to see parts of this movie
it kind of seems like stuff he made for
X-Men first Class is going to be
featured in Deadpool 3 somehow what from
X-Men first Class could come back in
Deadpool 3 at the top of that list Kevin
Bacon Sebastian Shaw maybe we'll get a
call back to Wolverine's [__] you in the
bar maybe we could get a restaging of
the events on that Cuban Beach because
notice that location that we've seen in
set leaks that is a sand covered ground
we might be looking at a beach of some
kind thank you so much for watching this
video big thanks to G Belo for writing
this script come check out our live show
in Los Angeles on February 15th at brain
dead Studios tickets still available in
the description below I'm Eric boss
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
bye